okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about
some features for version 12.2 of of
language which is coming soon
and these are features about uh
geography and dates
and i was trying to run a prototype
build here
which is absolutely refusing to run so
you've sent me examples
so i mean that's kind of pathetic but
let me let me just um
let me just kill off that prototype
build so it doesn't open something
okay by the way we have a lot of
background noise i don't know whether
this is some
just wind noise type okay
so what should we look at first here are
we going to look at vector geographics
first
yeah i think so it's magnificent
um
those sections down there under geo in
the
design notebooks list sort of the
various sub problems like labels
tiles and styles okay so do we have
somebody from design here
can we get somebody from design who
worked on those on the styles
tim okay is tim here
no but we can probably get him
okay because i'd like to see those
different styles
i don't think we are fine all this came
in kind of
kind of late there is
here you see the various styles
yeah but randomly i mean oh i see here
there are eight in total
have we shown these to graphic design as
well
so we need to cut them to look at them
i mean they look nice but
is someone calling tim or i just sent
him a message on rocket chat
if he doesn't respond there then i'll
give him a call in a minute
i didn't organize this particularly as a
sort of a style
review meeting which in which case we
would have prepared a little bit
different documentation so you can
oh ben is here ben should be dealing
with this
um tim's on his way
is ben here i'm here okay good
okay
so this is our def our okay vector
classic
well these are very nice
they look really nice and now the it's
all
vector there it's all scalable
we have another section there in which
you see the different zooms
and how the the the detail and the
the content changes by zoom so this is
all now working
yes yes it is working and it's fast and
all that
there's no speed problem um well right
now it's working with a tile server
in lima and it's slow but once we move
the
tiles to the gear server or the cdn then
it will be a bit faster we should move
it to the cdn
please is that in process
yup we're in talks with warren et cetera
talks isn't
isn't convincing it's been explored
apparently he has been asking questions
to the city and
people and they are not very receptive
so
i'm going to be doing tests because the
main problem
here is the huge amount of tiles
okay all right what is that timescale
because that's a thing that has to be
solved in the next week right
um well it has to be solved for the
release
for the moment of release i know but i
think we need to solve it quicker
because i think we need to be testing it
for a while
the good news here is that everything
related to styles is backlit updatable
so i'd like to change something in the
styles we can do it the styles
live in the year server so here you see
the zooming
around london level by level
these maps are really nice well why did
that jump i just clicked it
it jumped
not sure what you mean well it it
changed size
when i when i just clicked on it might
be something to do with the different
versions that you created
okay why is this taking so long to
this is not these maps are as large in
terms of data they contain
multiple megabytes of primitives
and if i'm to take this if i take this
and i say
image of this
okay so now is this an image now
it should be
it's got the toolbar oh yeah
and it's frozen pretty much
this is also very large notebook it's
much better 100 17 megabytes
okay just for the image okay
all right let's see this going zoom
levels
those streets are a bit thick at that
zoom level
how come it doesn't look quite right
yes so as i said this is the type of
thing that we can
change okay i just clicked here
okay and it jumped
see that i'm going to click in the
middle there
and now it jumped does it happen if you
take the notebook magnification back
down to 100
i wonder if there's like a bitmap cache
sort of thing
going on
no let's try a different one
it does not
it doesn't i think these roads are too
thick here
and we have tim now so okay these are
looking beautiful tim
okay thanks but i think the roads are
too
yup okay i'll make a note
you know i mean this is just like what
it's a bundle of yarn you know it's a
bundle of roads which you don't think is
reality i think that
as you go in
now i have no idea at that level whether
they're to scale
oh boy i happen to go there and see a
person i know from um last year how
interesting
so the data right now leaves up to zoom
14
and from sun 14 we have effectively the
same data it's just been
controlled by the styles what is shown
and what not
so we can go i think francisco to level
24 something like that here we're
showing 20.
now we can go deeper with image styles
okay well so
the only thing i have a problem with
this is the thickness of roads here
okay
they're really beautiful these things
okay external styles what is this oh i
see this is
osm's styles and things like that
exactly these are all the styles we have
taken from someone else
but now we can create many styles and
that's correct right
now what about backgrounds that have
gotten from like the nasa i mean
that's going to be separate the geo
image stuff right
right exactly yes now
something that we need to decide how to
do right now we are controlling the
different
types of vector maps via the geo
background option
and you saw the convention we use we put
vector in front of the values
styles rather than having say your
background goes to street map
and then we control the type with a
geotheme
or some some type of
of map style perhaps
you're quite quiet let's say what
oh yes i lowered my volume because it's
it's my headset that produces that
noise steven was complaining about
pressure
yes i'm i'm discussing with c7 how to
fix it
um
okay so so the question is
i mean geo background i can also say
presumably satellite there
right for geo background
yes exactly but then all the vector maps
disappear
obviously
so what we want to do for the next
version is to have some sort of control
of layers so that you can overlay these
on the satellite map
or you can select i want only the
streets only the
whatever
yes
we're not going to have some horrible
problem what's up
sorry yeah this section so
can you scale both maps and see the
difference
so you see how the labels stay same size
here
what's that
i think you just hit the thing so that
it changed the image margins or
something
and of course control z doesn't work
[Music]
perhaps and by control z you mean
command z
and that bug should be reported ben
that was did you see that yep i got it
okay
okay so there are the labels
i don't have a cube please just say
vector map scaled fonts true
font scaling
vector map font scaling arrow automatic
i would say
versus none
but do you have a preference of what
should be the different
what does tim think well we should ask
jeremy i don't know
i i'm i would say it would be the
the the type that stays the same size
the top one yeah that's what i think too
yeah that's what i think keep it the
same size
for now okay
this stuff is really beautiful i i've
said that about five times but i
i'm i'm just continuing to say that
uh thank you
um great all right let's move on
right then the
next thing we are then these three new
objects your polygon your boundary
ray geo bounds region boundary and the
thing
is we have this table of all our
primitives except for geomarker
the column on the left are the 2d
primitives the columns on the right are
the 1d primitives
so we wanted to have the the boundaries
of all of them
and the objects of all of them
and also geopolygon is a new object that
is aware of of topology
it uses the polygons with holes notation
so it was introduced for 12
and it can specify the type of path of
the edges
so things that we could not specify with
polygonal position before
okay that's good hey by the way what
earth has happened to things like sphere
position the whole
you know just the trivial packaging
repackaging of the geo stuff for spears
well my worry there has been always to
advance
two early spherical geometry which i
think should come from the geometry
team rather than the geo team
but i mean now that roger is here
perhaps i mean
do you have plans for spherical geometry
in the future no
we didn't i don't think you should i
don't think you should go there i think
i think what we should do
is simply have you know really just
you know sphere distance you know just
like we have geo distance
geosphere i'm sorry sphere distance all
those kinds of things
or spherical distance or spherical
polygon those kinds of things
i i think that's i think that that we
get
95 of the benefit by just taking what is
essentially
unitless datums
you know from the geo stuff and and yes
there is even more that can be done when
you start
doing i mean i you know don't
doesn't a lot of the region geometry
stuff work
in the geo case roger yes but it works
in two ways
either you're you use the full 3d
embedding
or you use the projection the 2d
projection yep
okay and it's very clear sort of which
one you're using depending on
how coordinates are given and so on how
do they
know well that has to be looked at but i
just think we should get a basic sphere
distance
you know sphere polygon et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and rendering of that which again i just
think we can just you know it's just
like
geo except without units
and with radians instead of degrees is
the default measurements and so on
i think we should talk about it depends
on how well you want it to actually work
if it's just graphics that's one thing
if it's also compute that's the
difference well i mean
look things like areas and so on we
should get that to work
but i just don't think we need i mean
i think we should see what we can get by
just taking the geo functionality and
putting it in the case and and
conveniently packaging it for
spheres and then see what we can't get
and maybe there will be some things we
can't get but let's cross that bridge
when we know what they are
what are applications of that why do you
want it
uh every so often i need it you know
every so often i'll have some reason why
i'm doing spherical geometry
spherical spherical you know where it
isn't geo
it's just spherical a good example good
example is
projections okay i've got a function
on a sphere really a function right
i've got an and i want to draw it and
you know i want to visualize it but i
want to do it with a map projection
obviously i can do it by pretending it's
a geo thing but it's kind of weird
you see what i'm saying
and i mean there's nothing that's that's
why i think it's that's why i'm
confident that it will work because i
have done these things
with our geo functionality it's just
kind of crazy because i'm dealing with
you know
things with units in the geosystem et
cetera et cetera et cetera and pretend
you know in multiplying my function by
the radius of the earth and things like
this
which is you know just unnecessary
right right
another place in which we will be using
spherical purely spherical
geometry would be astro because they are
there there are no ellipsoids
right right but the plan is to use
degrees
as well yeah i think for astro we should
use degrees for spheres we should use
radians i mean if you just look around
you know i don't know like like i was
doing um i mean
eventually we want things like
hyperbolic geometry as well
but for now spherical geometry is a
really good start
okay now what's all this stuff so
geopolygon should i look at the
reference page for geopolygon
yes
so san marino works
does antarctica work
yes right so here
here we will for example a problem we
had before
was this confusing of one side of the
wall or the other one
and now we will be able to specify an
interior point or an exterior point and
that will be resolved
okay in cartesian space stephen one
region is bounded the other one is
unbounded so it's clear
in this space in this case overbounded
but by the way i'm sorry to
make this point but we've obviously got
to go through and regenerate all the all
the um
uh geographics examples in the
documentation for the new
styles
the new styles for geographics that
don't look the same right
well we yes this is something we didn't
discuss before
we were planning to have the new styles
not as default but something that the
users have to opt in
by specifying the background they have
to use
i don't think it's a i think we should
have it by default
yes i have the impression we haven't
tested it well enough all right fine
so then for this version we don't have
to have it by default exactly in 13 we
have it by default
or 123.
okay so roger your point is there's an
obvious exterior
if you're in an unbounded space but
there isn't if you're in a bounded space
right and jose figured out what
you know if you look at the table he
made up there actually look at the
examples they're
good but as i figured out various
convenient ways of doing it
support various convenient ways of doing
it
right if somebody tells you the polygon
the boundary of my polygon is the
equator how do you know which side do
you mean
yeah are you an ordinary obviously it's
the northern half
i mean what else could it be how would
you deal with that
there case defaults yes it will choose
probably the north
it's like yes when you have to the
geodesic between two points in the
equator
if it has to go through a pole you will
choose the north
do we document that anywhere um
i'm not sure probably we don't yet
okay
interior is the smaller what's left and
right i don't understand that
what how can go ahead
because this is done with polygons so
the points on the boundary are sorted
they have to be traversed
in a given order so as you traverse the
points of the boundary
you leave the area on one side or the
other one
wait a minute is this a left hand rule
or a right hand rule or what
almost so imagine that you are
traversing the points of the boundary of
the u.s
in clockwise form then you are leaving
the interior
on the right that is utterly confusing
to me
i mean i would prefer to say here you
know
clockwise interior or something or
something like that
that's what you're saying is when the
points are traversed in clockwise order
but you still have to specify the points
are
the points they're traversed into order
given right
yes i know but i don't understand what
the left and right is then the the
if the point is walk along the edge of
the polygon
yeah is it to the left or the right
i see wait a minute i'm very confused uh
i'm i'm very bad at these two magical
visualization things okay you're walking
around a pond
the pond is to your right yes that's
right
okay the pond is always in one direction
one side or the other
yes god that's confusing
okay i think that's why roger wants i
mean
how do you describe it to people when
you talk to people you must have been
using this in everyday life
no the house is on the right hand side
of the road when you come from the
town or my house is on the left-hand
side
when you come from you know you must
have used it a lot
yes but not in the case whether it's a
circular area
i mean i'm thinking about the equator if
my
geopolygon is a hemisphere
i guess it still works i guess there
still is a left and a right
okay i believe it
okay what is the geographic path type
what's that for that's for the boundary
oh i see exactly oh this is interesting
yeah okay fine
this is a good thing right
and this closes the gap that now we can
compute the boundary of this object and
it will give you a geopath of the same
type
this is showing that yeah different yeah
right this is a very good
idea this is a good idea this is our
topology so now we'll
uh projections and things like that uh
yeah we will know what to do
so so now country borders become
geopolygons is that correct
so if we take a a country like france or
something and we say
of polygon arguably we should have a new
property named geopolygon
that gives you the geopolygon because i
think there's a too much code that will
use
the fact that it is a genuine polygon
otherwise
um well this is this is something you
were
asking recently whether we should change
from field curves
to other things so the plan was to
change from field curves to use directly
geopolygon with
holes with the arrows okay fine but i
mean if i say something like
france and then i say polygon what am i
actually getting
so right now a projected thing so
right now it's a polygon of your
position
okay and you're proposing but so so long
as the
geometry functions work with geopolygons
i'm a happy person
yes they will they have an interface a
common interface to the geo framework
and that interface knows about your
polygon
i don't know what this is that's the
external build that's just hanging right
i don't think it's the hexagonal build
no
oh okay it's the 12 one build
what'd you do to your 12 one pill i have
no idea
okay all right let's go on geo
boundary yes so that's the function that
communicates the two columns
so given to the the origin on the left
it will give you for example something
something simple we
could never do do you have this polygon
of friends give me the boundary
of friends what's the analog
that's region boundary is the analog
otherwise right
yes
what the heck is going on here
okay
fine
okay is there okay geo bounds region
boundary
yes it's a bit of a mouthful but that
was the only case we had
without a boundary object
we had things like uh geovision
the visible region boundary your
hemisphere boundary
so this this is a rectangle in lat lawn
so this is the boundary of that why is
it just a geopolygon
oh because that's interior it could be
but i think this is more specific
and and you see that i would like to
have this table complete
yeah okay okay
um question
what is is that
j hemisphere knight hemisphere of those
separate
functions yes we have two for them with
a date
so they take an as argument a date and
then the boundary is the day night
terminator between them
yeah i understand okay so
um question for geopolygon
i assume that it can have an edge form
for graphics yes
uh yes internally it will be eventually
converted into graphics
so all the things that can be done with
normal polygons can be done with them
so edge form red on geopolygon will just
work
well this is great actually will the
fillings work in geographics
the new fillings uh they should i mean
there's a need
there's a neat example in hatch filling
using
uh the countries in africa okay
oh yeah i remember seeing that yeah so
that will work even with geopolygon
yes so all these objects you see there
in that table
they are all in the end converted into
either point
line or polygon right
so they inherit everything from them
okay
okay uh all right and nothing more to
look at here
um no i don't think so uh roy had
prepared the
specific material if you wanted to
discuss how labels work and
or tiles them
so that's a case in which you see the
huge amount of data that
we receive for example francisco was
recently checking how many times
something is used for four points in a
map
and it turned out to be 45 000.
what do you mean points of interest
so so in this kind of maps we had like
around 45
000 elements that we need to
prove resolve the collisions etc yes
okay in real time and how do you do that
it's it's uh we have encoded an r3 a
very fast r3 algorithm
okay but how do you know what's
important
oh they do come sorted yep
so osm already provides all the
information you need to do
the things it says that you have to
write your algorithms to do them
although i do think that for some future
version that might be something we want
to look at
what the sorting is yeah what is
important
yeah i agree because i don't think pain
stations are necessarily important to
people
right that was something that google
focused on
whereas apple focused on uh
points of interest and discovery
right can we get an inventory of what
the categories
on a typical street level map and then a
typical i mean because there is
commentary basically that is going on
when you're deciding trains are
important you know
whatever is i mean like we're not seeing
the train lines we're just seeing the
trains here
maybe we are seeing some train lines
maybe these are mostly subway
does madrid have a subway let's let's
ask the very basic question
yes absolutely yes okay so these are not
mostly
right but these are these are
underground train because there aren't
train tracks here
exactly it's all underground even the
train lines
right okay
okay but so yes we absolutely should
figure that out
what what the categories are and what
and then what the sorting should be
but many of these things can also be
done at the style level
so so you can have different styles that
focus on on different elements for
example
on categories well that's fine but but
let's get a list
please let's have a separate meeting
where we have lists of these things and
we can start to see
you know what what the consequences are
okay now what's this about
yes so this is just a case in which we
had a river
that's the star command rebar near
champagne and this is an example of how
we
select many candidate boxes to uh
place the label and they are sorted by
opacity so
the darker ones are the best ones
based on where it's straightest exactly
this is interesting i mean we should
un-package
some of this functionality so that
people can use it to label things
themselves i mean like labeling a curve
on a graph i don't see why we shouldn't
use the same technology
yes actually we are internally
developing a full language
to specify the rotations the separations
uh yeah multiple things but i mean
you know what i think we want
is you know something like a co-labelled
thing or so i i know some term like that
that means
label the thing with a
you know a kind of a a
co co-moving label if you understand
what i'm saying brett you understand
what i'm saying
you've got a curve and a plot i want to
label it the same way you're labeling
streets
right i've got three curves i want to
label them you know using the same
avoidance algorithms and the same
positioning algorithms
right you you want the labels along the
curve
yes yeah
well actually i just want the labels
whatever you're doing for maps
to give a decent experience with
labeling do that
you see what i'm saying so a curve gets
something a point gets something et
cetera et cetera et cetera
right and and same for you know i know
you have some algorithms for
for feature space plot and so on that
prune down the labels
i'm just saying you know this is a
technology and we've had for years we've
had ones for console plots
but i i really think we should have a
you said you're developing a language to
represent this i really think that's an
important thing
okay right and we're talking with jose
and francisco and
yeah it's tackling the labeling from
both sides
okay yeah from geo and from phase okay
so terrific well lovely work okay let's
move on in this
in this meeting okay array classes
what's that about it's kind of a detail
but when you specify matrices
it can be symmetric and anti-symmetric
and to support complex matrix variables
we needed hermitian and antihermitian
and this goes with what with symmetric
matrices you know we have arrays i know
that i know that i know that i know that
we've already got hermitian matrix q
right right
okay so we've got this notion of
symmetric that is a
characterization of a thing right and
you're saying her mission
is a characterization like symmetric
yes exactly it falls it goes into the
same framework
fine something that something special
here
is that the standard case is hermitian
matrix that's why it's separated
the second case is one of these
generalizations that is natural
in the language in the language of
symmetries but i've never seen it before
i've never i've never seen anybody using
it
so right it's a tensor and that's
because
people
that's because there's matrix mechanics
but not tensor mechanics and quantum
mechanics
right right so
my my impression about this is that this
is a generalization that makes level at
the array
level make sense at the right level but
not in the geometric level of tensors so
this is a condition that is not
invariant under changes of bases for
example
things like that so so perhaps this
should be documented under
extensions and not as a main thing
oh i don't know let's just entertain
people by putting it in there
it's not going to hurt anything
um i would i
if you really want to know when she sent
something to
xerxes and jonathan and ask what happens
in categorical quantum mechanics i
wouldn't be surprised if this concept
isn't there
and the only reason to do that is just
to check we didn't get the concept wrong
okay but this seems fine i have explicit
examples of
of arrays that obey that condition
okay
that seems fine okay should we go on
okay date select do we have um nick here
to represent this
that yep not a very beautiful picture
yet
yeah it's sort of our tentative idea of
you know we wanted to have
a illustration that sort of showed the
idea of picking out dates based on some
sort of pattern or some sort of
recurring sequence
okay returns all dates within the date
interval for which criterion of date
i is true
okay
yeah so what what we're doing is to use
the as if association
mechanism here is that right yeah
basically so we can
in effect use any element that's valid
in date value
as to construct a boolean expression of
arbitrary complexity
so we can pick out you know basic
elements of the month is this value
or the day of week is this value this is
pretty reasonable
but now how is that implementationally
what does that look like does it
construct
the association and then apply this so
how does it work yeah so basically under
the hood we have
a we have a couple of different steps to
try and optimize the process but we
basically
pick out whatever elements we need to
generate the elements needed by the
criteria we try and do a fast pass on
anything that's simple
you know if i say it needs to be within
this year i can drop out whatever dates
don't match that
pattern and then we basically try to
selectively apply
and filter out so we're only doing the
necessary evaluations
to pick out things that are actually
true if i only need wednesdays that's a
relatively simple
thing to pick out
okay new calendars and date object
and so the primary documentation for the
new calendars is
on the calendar data new page but we've
been
cleaning up the way that it's referenced
on some of these other pages and trying
to improve the documentation a little
bit too
[Music]
okay so whatever happened what did we do
again with the um
uh um
with that exchange data about hollow
that was a different thing
yeah that's a different thing so we're
working with alan
um on basically taking the data we've
collected for alpha
making a proper exposed version of that
and then basically cleaning up the data
so we can have a you know a data packet
that says
i want you know russian religious
holidays i want
whatever sort of holidays are associated
with this exchange or i want a
collection of exchanges that observe
law you know being able to basically
leverage the the
implicit entity framework also uh so we
don't have
a whole bunch of named entity classes
sounds good to me holiday calendar of a
good
country what you don't mean this
that's an that's an error
given the country entity of the country
no you mean something different there
the holiday calendar is given as the
what are you talking about here so
basically so this is the old version of
calendar data did some aspect of this
exchange uh holiday system
and so we're continuing to support that
but basically
if you said that but that sentence is
incomprehensible right right
yeah it specifies it's specified as
i think if you say calendar data
france i assume it gives you french
holidays or something yes that's that's
what i think happened but but i think
yeah
sorry the the sentence there is not
clear so yeah the
is specified as a country entity
so if you want national holidays for
france you could say holiday
calendar goes to france basically
right and then we've
done a little bit of work in terms of
creating some
different basic classes for date
calendars like there are astronomical
calendars and
arithmetic calendars and in the future
there may be regnal calendars or
some other subset um from there
those are cut classes as well yeah yeah
so
in principle all calendars are
astronomical
to a degree but the arithmetic ones have
simplified rules and don't
actually do on-the-fly
uh calculations of moon phase etc
okay so are these going to have
documentation papers the
balinese
so we hadn't planned on having specific
calendar
type pages
but we have because you can say calendar
data of
a given calendar we can get information
about it
but by the way what on earth is the
ordering of the calendars here
from coptic to western baha'i what how
did they come to be in that order uh
they they should be i need to resort
these alphabetically within each section
okay i was copying and pasting things so
they they got a little out of whack but
yeah it should be alphabetical in each
section
okay just says holocene and that says
hello scene
oh it should be holocene
i don't know it is yes it's
in
so this tentative section i would really
put the recently proposed mathematic
calendars at the bottom
okay
they're really not winners they're
they're interesting but yeah they're
probably not frequently used
right
the heck is that one
it's a perennial calendar i don't
remember offhand what the big difference
between it in the world calendar but the
idea is that
you know january 1st of every year is
always going to be
a sunday or a monday oh i see
right so every trimester has a month
with four weeks another with five
another with four
and then again and again yeah that's
right
so each trimester has the same calendar
and why are you not going back before
yeah minus a thousand
uh so this was just sort of a table to
show the the change
um as we you know that the astronomical
calendars account for changing
yeah i understand that i mean i think
you should show i mean we care about
look recorded history goes back at least
five thousand
to you know maybe 5000 bc okay
yeah i can make that table a little
bigger i didn't know if this was
something that was entirely relevant for
the the page at the top here but i
thought it was an interesting way to
show the differences and
i hope it's useful i think it's useful
to let people know that there are really
weird complicated issues like this
okay excellent might go to a different
place in the um
this is information that will be
available directly through the astro
functionality in the next version
okay it will be a more proper place to
have these things
would it make sense to format that
middle column in something that is not
fractions of a day
you know like hours minutes seconds so
you can
these no these ones we want we want
fractional days
i mean the your minus 1 000 too
yeah i kind of like keeping it
consistent with the other columns oh
this is good
this is good we don't want we don't want
anything this is
you know 0.24218
oh yeah that's what i remember as 0.24
and for the current time
yeah boy
in my lifetime then it'll only be the
next digit that changes okay
uh
right okay let's move on okay that was
calendar data
calendar convert that was we already
know what that's going to do
yep and same thing with calendar type
they basically we have some of the
additional information like the
parameterized versions of calendars
and then we also link uh here for
more data about calendars what's this
thing with julian here that that's not
is that that's not a function is it or
is it
i mean we've got julian date don't we as
a function already
um yeah we do and so
the notion is to sort of expand on these
in the future
of having baseline year julian near they
can both be
a calendar system and they're also
useful standalone functions
well fractional then that means but i
mean current we could
we could have a thing called current
year
if we wanted to yeah it's basically
current
date of year that we well it's basically
now of quotes here isn't it
yep i don't know that we want current
yet but i mean
when we give the julian euro the
besellin year that'll have fractional
year components right
but they have a very precise definition
so the for example for the definition of
julie india
is that starting from the 1st of january
of year 2000 at
noon to count 365.25
exactly days in every direction
okay around year 2000 is very precise
it's more or less precise as you get
further away they
get totally misaligned but that's what
the astronomers use that's very precise
definition i thought it was relative to
1900
i thought the barcelona was like 1800 or
something
no it's the other round the basilian
year is around
uh well the basilian year is
need you need to know the duration of
every year and you interpolate between
years
but it's centered around 19
1950. really
yes but bessel wasn't around in 1950
but but that's the convention so you can
do
it's just a convention what in the same
way that julian years are centered
around
uh 2000 and at some point people will
start using duty and years around
2050 because they will not bother to go
to
year 2000 i see okay and you're saying
it's not based on
55 bc or something
right okay all right let's move on
this is looking wonderful okay data set
yes so these are just some uh
some things we are working on on data
set and
actually right now what uh chris is
working
most of uh most intensely are plot
themes
and uh data set editing
and i'm working on the on the type
system
what is the theme what are the themes
being called
um well probably bretton team can't
report more on that
they have also been working on that i
mean the major themes follow the same
what's the option name i
don't know that it has a name yet it's i
don't know if it's going to be data set
theme or if it's going to be something
else
i mean i doubt it will be plot theme but
well but it's time is of the essence
we'll you know
i mean the themes aren't a 12-2 feature
oh okay
okay so what is the 12-2 feature all the
stuff chris has been doing
and robustness and improvement of the
formatting right
right right exactly yes and and
editing might be the the only thing that
he has uh for this version
there's something for for me i have been
working on this new type system but
i would like to test it a lot more so so
probably it will not be by default
uh usable in interruption
okay but but just so i understand all
the stuff to do with max items and so on
that's all 12 2
right yes that's not there yes
that's new in 12-2 no no my side names
and those things were in 12-1
it is that he has improved the
robustness of all of that a lot
with with
yes we documented those so if in 121
dataset had i think
11 or 12 new options and they were all
augmented
okay okay fine but they work a lot
better right now
okay okay and but editing is is going to
be a new thing
um it's not merged yet so
um i don't really know but but he's
working hard on that
okay okay sounds good
uh all right i think um that looks like
it's everything
i'm really pleased with some of these
things especially the vector maps
um all right i think we have another
group of people here for a different
meeting but i think it may have some
overlap
um do we have the folks here for the
um databand submit stuff yep yes
okay all right let's just i'm gonna
leave this map up because i think it's
so beautiful
um and uh then let's just segue to that
meeting
um anything anything else from from
roger and um
jose and so on no no
you covered it all okay would it be
useful
to be able to get out this list of
of um uh of labels somehow
as a list
it's all there in the map but it's it's
all in a
format that is tailored towards graphics
not
towards computation no i understand that
but i'm saying
each one of those has a geo position
being able to get the list of of points
out
where it's literally a string and you
know
it's a type a string a geo position
it's basically a map data type thing
yeah i think so
i think eventually we will be able to do
that but probably
there are things we can install in the
jio server
that will that are specifically designed
for that
type of query but i mean so but what i'm
saying is just
what oh i see that because these are
pre-tile pre-generated tiles
right now right so these things are all
given in a way that is especially good
for graphics but not for computation
i understand but so what i'm imagining
is that one could say
give me all points of interest within
this geo region and so on so it's
basically a geo within
functionality it's basically geo within
but it's basically what it would be is
geo within
instead of like city it would be
something like geo label
or something within
see what i'm saying and it would just
give you a bunch of strings
or just geo geo within name
um or geo nearest of quotes name
comma position comma 300 or something
and we'll give you the 300
closest names to that
anyway okay just something for the
future
okay all right let's switch to the next
topic thanks guys
yes okay bye-bye
okay data bin submit is that what's
coming next
yes do i need to update
no
i'm sure you have in the last two days i
certainly have yes
all right databand submit what is it all
right
it's the url submit version of
databandhead
so it's a it's a fire and forget it's a
fire and forget
so instead of an ad but it happens in
the background and you get a task
back desk object back instead of uh
instead of the data bin back
sounds sensible to me yeah it's pretty
straightforward
the one that last note is the one catch
that we might want to improve ux for
at some point but i wasn't sure
it wasn't a it wasn't a half hour job um
so it's very easy to hit rate limits
with this because they're queuing up in
the background
and when you hit the rate limits the
messages show up in the message window
what what do you mean the rate limit i
don't understand why is there a rate
limit for these they just q
q q q q well they're
it's it's easier to send things f
send things at a faster rate i
understand but why aren't they just
queuing
up they don't get put in the data bin
they hit the rate limit and so they just
queue up
maybe they queue up for three hours
well that's just we're talking you're
talking about a server side change there
right yes but i'm i'm saying if you have
a thing called databand submit i don't
think it's a rate limit
well then read this it's going to have
to be after 12 too
that's a major infrastructure listen to
what i'm saying to you
okay this there's no way that a thing
which is based on
you know the actual final insertion can
be rate limited but it should queue up
how does it actually work it's just
doing url submit
and why doesn't that just work why
doesn't that just
what does it do when it rate limits the
server gives an error message
which is returned to the user
okay so that's not going to work so you
need more careful thinking
about how to deal with it queuing up but
it's not necessary for 12 2 right
right your solution is awful
to this but but i mean right it's
uh it's my solution is documenting it
clearly so that people are warned
uh
okay but i don't think we should
document it like that okay so then then
you have to treat this as an
experimental function
sure okay
all right anything else to figure out
with this no
no i think it's yeah pretty
straightforward what
in the in the 90 use case 99
use case all right good
i mean uh yeah so you do it
it automatically just turns into a task
now how do you find out that the task
has been
you have to pick up that task and query
it to find out whether the data
right the output is a task object just
like any other test object you can say
test status
and all the other uh post fixed
things that you do on a task object
okay
um
okay sounds good um all right well well
done all right so i'll take down the
future and put up uh
experimental and we're good sounds good
to me
that was good thank you very much all
right okay have a good weekend
guys okay bye